[Music]
the meg is a summer blockbuster shark
film starring Jason Statham and Ruby
Rose early reactions to the mag are
calling it the perfect popcorn flick and
the film is set to be 2018 s biggest
monster movie originally based on the
1997 book meg and novel of deep terror
the movie diverts from its source
material slightly and throughout this
video I'll be discussing the film's plot
and ending as well as the main
differences to the novella there will of
course be heavy spoilers here so it may
be worth skipping this video until
you've had a chance to watch the film if
you want to remain unspoiled without the
way I'm definition and I ruin the movie
so you don't have to wracked with guilt
after failing to rescue underwater
divers Jonas Taylor finds redemption
when he is tasked with saving the crew
of the Man O'War
mana Wan is a marine research station
that is conducting scientific
experiments that involve exploration
into unsure of the ocean after
suspecting that one of their deep sea
vessels has been attacked by a Megalodon
Mack played by Cliff Curtis decides that
Taylor should attempt a rescue mission
and sends the diver after the apparently
doomed crew whilst they wait for Taylor
to journey from Thailand
suyin one of the mana wands crew
attempts her own rescue mission Taylor
follows her and ends up rescuing other
crew members warlin Celeste
however Tashi who was part of the deep
sea died realizes that the Megalodon
will kill the rest of the crew on their
return if it breaks free and closes the
passage to his ship sacrificing himself
so that others can escape back at mana
wan the station receives a signal that
many sharks are broken through the
depths of the ocean
including the Megalodon what follows is
an attempt to track down the giant beast
and inject poison into it before can
reach the mainland while the crew does
succeed in doing that with a shark a
case of mistaken identity forces them to
kill the wrong one and the Megalodon
attacks the crew eating and injuring
several of them the other survivors
attempt other attacks including shooting
the Megalodon from a helicopter with
grenades but this fails and when Taylor
concludes that the Megalodon is enroute
to a local Chinese beach he anaxes final
plan drawing the gigantic shark away
from the beach Taylor manages to cut the
monster which attracts other sharks to
it and they feast on the Megalodon
finally killing it in the process whilst
the story of the film follows the book
slightly there are still some major
differences the source material has
several megalodons in it and also
contains an appearance from a t-rex in
the novel's prologue which takes place
during the Cretaceous period a
Tyrannosaurus Rex stumbles into the
ocean and is devoured by the real apex
predator of the age the Megalodon mana
one does not feature in the book like it
does in the film however Taylor does set
out to rescue a doom submarine with his
friend Tanaka in the novel when they
arrive at the trench Jonas and Tanaka
Serna
dive into small submersibles out of
nowhere a male Megalodon rises from the
deaths and kills snacker son Paul to the
surface by steel wiring as the Beast
attacks Tanaka son a second larger
female Megalodon rises out of the trench
and she attacks the male and feeds on
him as he's pulled to the surface is
heated blood protects her from the cold
water layer that has previously kept
megalodons from entering the wider ocean
and she escapes into the wild an apex
predator like this being introduced into
the ecosystem of the ocean has a massive
effect and is one of the biggest
concerns for Jonas in the book the
Megalodon attacks San Diego not China
and Jonas also discovered that the
Megalodon is pregnant Tanaka and Jonas
managed to track down the female as she
gives birth and after sliding down her
throughout managed to kill her from the
inside the baby that the Megalodon
produces would later go on to star on
the book sequel and the book ends with
Jonas throwing the Megalodon tooth into
the ocean back where it belongs it's a
great story and I definitely recommend
that you pick it up especially if you're
a shark fan it's got loads of cool
moments in it and it kept me on my seat
throughout reading it so what did you
think of the Meg have you read the book
and what did you prefer out of
and the film comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you'll love if
you're a fan of film recently I did a
video discussing how Donna's managed to
survive Stormbreaker being thrown into
his chest so make sure you check that
out next thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]